do you feel different do you have to
hide your true self from others are you
frankly a bit of a weirdo then let's be
honest normal school isn't for you you
deserve better
you deserve met Pat's guide to young
adult schools for mutants monsters and
magic users
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the YouTube show guaranteed to get you a
perfect score on the SATs actual number
of the perfect score may vary boy the
year summer is long over in students
across the world have returned to school
to reluctantly learn math history and
Transfiguration Oh was that a last one
not offered to you well maybe you're
just at the wrong school as we've
learned from the last ten years of young
adult movies and fiction magical schools
are everywhere there are schools for
vampires schools for mutants schools for
magicians even schools for magicians who
want to get a little action on the side
oh they're kids let's lower those wands
a bit shall we
but with so many options out there how
can I find the best school for my needs
well fear not because that's the
question I plan on answering today which
magical school is objectively the best
I'm ranking through the most prestigious
fictional schools for gifted students of
our time
Hogwarts from Harry Potter Xavier's
school for gifted youngsters from the
x-men series and the new kid on the
block miss peregrine's home for peculiar
children simply because it's different
and because the movie is coming out it
has just come out whenever you watch
this video and because it's actually a
pretty interesting series but how do we
go about ranking these schools well in
real life there are multiple lists like
the US News & World Report which serve
as ranking systems to compare schools
based on criteria like average class
size job placement rates classes offered
things like that it's like the one type
of listicle that WatchMojo hasn't milked
dry at this point it's not giving them
any ideas anyway in preparing for
today's episode I settled on the formula
used by one of the most well respected
rating systems the Princeton Review
which rates each school according to
eight different categories so how does
some of the world's best magical schools
stack up we're about to find out oh and
in case it isn't obvious your choice at
school will involve a couple of spoilers
for these movies so be warned then again
your education is too important so let's
not waste any more time let's go
category one academics the first thing
you think about when it comes to a
school is how good are their classes and
how diverse is their curriculum all
academic courses at Hogwarts are in two
teaching students about the Wizarding
World and will they do a good job of it
students only learn about the Wizarding
World from what we can tell in the books
and movies there's only one class muggle
studies that's related to the outside
world at all and because of this
graduates from Hogwarts can care for a
flower worm but can't you know do things
like read frigging calculating a tip at
a restaurant because they've literally
never taken a math class instead the
closest Hogwarts students get is a
rhythm NC which is predicting the future
through numbers basically numerology
Illuminati confirmed and that's not to
mention everything else that they're
clueless about you must know all about
Mongoose what exactly is the function of
a rubber duck right miss Peregrine
school by contrast is much more
concerned with teaching students to
defend themselves or stay hidden they do
teach regular subjects which is why this
qualifies as a school but the problem is
that the school is stuck in a time loop
back in 1940 this means all the students
are missing almost 75 years of history
technology Game of Thrones episodes
everything in fact miss Peregrine's
deliberately hides information from her
students to ensure that they never leave
don't get me wrong I love you miss PE
but it might be time to upgrade to some
newfangled learning tools like say
8-track tapes cassette decks laser discs
by the way do school still use laser
discs it was always so random when a
teacher would pull one of those things
out what's a laser disk you ask well
basically the record sized compact discs
what's a record
what's a compact disc man I feel ancient
so that leaves us with Xavier's school
for gifted youngsters which is
surprisingly designed to be just like an
ordinary private school as a student
there you'll be learning normal history
signs in English in between phys ed
classes featuring laser eye target
practice in fact according to the x-men
Survival Guide to the mansion every
student must impart be premed no joke
mixing algebra with magnetic satellite
moving the curriculum here is clearly
the most balanced first point to house
Xavier category to financial aid a key
consideration in any college decision is
how much funding the school provides for
its students to less
the crippling debt it'll put them in for
the next ten years of their lives
lucky for our gifted students all three
of our schools are set up like safe
houses on top of just being places of
higher education as a result there's no
tuition no bursar bills and no student
loans hanging over your head upon
graduation come to think about it that's
probably the single most fictional thing
about these fictional schools you gotta
pay those student loans but probably
shouldn't have taken that extra course
in ethics a but with Hogwarts you've
really got to read your fine print
because before you can say Petrificus
Totalus you're getting hit with all
sorts of hidden fees you've got to have
your robes your cauldron your wand all
those books including the one that
literally bites you
Hogwarts even has a pet on the
back-to-school shopping list and we know
that this stuff is expensive a universal
studios of Waddell runya $50 thing is
even a magic wand it's like a plastic
remote control has less functionality
than a Wii mote oh look I turned on the
lantern thanks for the magical
experience Universal doesn't even have a
phoenix feather in there I mean Harry is
lucky enough to have two dead parents
who left him with a cavern full of gold
to pay his bills but a middle-income
family like the Weasleys need to use all
hand-me-down robes books and even rats
as a result the points for this round go
to both miss Peregrine's and Xavier
school categories three and four faculty
Princeton Review has two categories here
one how qualified and two how accessible
the teachers are miss Peregrine's has
the greatest disadvantage here since it
only has one faculty member and on the
experience side miss Peregrine's may be
well-versed in peculiar dumb yes for
those of you who haven't read the books
or seen the movie yet that is what they
call their special ability it's a good
series of books but it is as ridiculous
as it sounds let's be honest her
qualifications as an actual teacher are
somewhat loose she grew up in the 1920s
and deliberately ignores any progress
made in science tech art and history I
suppose you could say that she's a bit
of a birdbrain cuz she's an in Bream
which have the ability to turn into
birds whatever it's a complicated
fictional world okay on the other hand
at least she has a lot of office hours
and makes breakfast for the whole class
it's not enough to get her the points
though by contrast the Hogwarts faculty
are all actual professors and fully
specialized in their subject a lot of
them have real
experience like mad-eye moody or are
known for their academic rigor like
Snape even their office hours are pretty
good I mean in most movies you can
barely avoid these teachers even if
you're literally wandering the halls at
3:00 a.m. under an invisibility cloak
for crying out loud
Dumbledore kept coming back to give area
advice even after he was dead and so
then what about Xavier 'he's well
unfortunately he just seems to scrape up
whatever mutants are available and throw
them into a random subject sure
Professor Charles Xavier has a doctorate
from Oxford but do you really think
Cyclops is qualified to teach geometry
he doesn't even have depth perception
and what about accessibility well
unfortunately the x-men are only
teaching in between major world crises
which basically happen all the time at
which point they take up their real jobs
as you know the x-men I think you're
gonna be scorned well on to a CT when
your teachers been gone for the last
three weeks trying to wrangle magneto
back into his little plastic box I don't
think so thus its Hogwarts far and away
that has the best faculty both in terms
of quality and accessibility two points
for house Hogwarts categories five and
six campus life and safety what good is
the quality of the education and the
training of the faculty if students are
living under constant fear of death a
school first and foremost needs to be
safe which when it comes to these
schools means these categories are just
awash sure Xavier looks like this
beautiful manner but hello it's built
over the x-men headquarters it's like
building Harvard on top of a nuclear
testing site in the span of a few
decades we literally see the school
overtaken by the military ransacked and
completely obliterated in the comics the
place gets destroyed like every ten
issues and while Hogwarts may seem like
the better option with its secluded
campus and great extracurricular
activities like Quidditch hogs meat and
dances it also has a tree in the front
yard that can eat cars a basilisk in the
plumbing a troll in the girls bathroom
as well as deadly spiders and angry
centaurs just off of school grounds and
that's not including the time Death
Eaters snuck their way through security
murdered the principal and destroyed the
castle in the middle of what amounted to
a Wizarding race war miss Peregrine's
seems like it should have the easy win
here right they literally repeat the
same sunny day over and over what could
possibly go wrong
well that's sunny day that they repeat
over and over again happens to be the
one where the school found itself in a
direct path with a world war two bomb
dropped
4head the only thing saving the students
every 24 hours is that it exists in a
time loop that resets when the bomb is
inches from landing that said if the
loop isn't reset that bomb will
literally demolish the school and all of
its inhabitants oh yeah I forgot to
mention if any of the students decide to
leave the loop
everyone will age forward by the 80
years they've missed and immediately die
so yeah no winners in these categories
geez it's a miracle anyone seems to even
graduate category 7 job prospects what's
the point of a school if not to get a
job after graduation I mean a school
that can get even their English majors
lucrative work is definitely doing
something right well even though Xavier
students learn normal school subjects
most of them are encouraged by Charles
himself to rejoin the world or stereo
and teach others and yet most students
end up just doing that second part
becoming part time teachers and
full-time x-men neither of which are
particularly stable jobs considering the
health risks we covered back in
categories 5 and 6 as for miss
Peregrine's because of that pesky time
loop students never age and considering
that they're all under 18 those
babyfaces are gonna hurt them in their
long term job prospects but honestly
it's not like any of that even matters
when you're stuck reliving the same day
over and over again it's not like you're
ever gonna make it to payday in the
first place and again there's that whole
leave the time loop and you die things
so let's just say that there are a few
hurdles to long term job security on
that one meanwhile most students at
Hogwarts graduate and settle into
magical jobs like ministry officials
dragon hunters Quidditch players which
easily puts Hogwarts at the top of this
category Hogwarts gains a point in job
prospects which means that our score
going into the final round is Hogwarts 3
Xavier school for gifted youngsters to
miss peregrine's home for peculiar
children at one point and since there's
only one category left does that mean
that this is basically over that there's
no way the other schools can take down
Hogwarts well don't be too sure let's
look at that last criteria category 8
selectivity of admissions now admittedly
at first glance this doesn't seem like
much of a game-changer
Xavier school for gifted youngsters
never rejects any mutant they'll even
admit mutants whose powers negate the
powers of other mutants or mutants who
have formerly destroyed the school or
muse that seduced the students seriously
they seem to accept everyone
Hogwarts too is open to Wizards from all
walks of life even if their parents are
the Mort supporters I'm looking at you
Draco and miss Peregrine's home is open
to anyone who exhibits peculiar symptoms
or is pale enough to star in a Tim
Burton film but when you really look at
the admissions process two of these
schools kind of suck institutions that
at their core are fundamentally
discriminatory ageist and ableist they
exclude people based on attributes they
have no control over like their genetics
and their physical abilities which would
be like Harvard only allowing men but
not just men only white men who are also
blond-haired and blue-eyed not born with
a peculiar soul well then sorry but
Peregrine's doors are shut Tia in fact
not only can non peculiars enter the
school's loop if they somehow manage to
enter campus grounds they would actually
lose their mind that's no exaggeration
they will literally lose their mind and
if you think that's bad Hogwarts
admissions practices are actually
illegal you see according to the
Pottermore official website Hogwarts
Admissions is dictated by the quill of
acceptance and the book of admittance
and the book has a perfect track record
of keeping squibs out of Hogwarts this
is also confirmed by JK Rowling on our
old official website that no squib has
ever attended Hogwarts no as a refresher
scripts like Argus Filch or non magic
children born to witches and wizards
basically their wizard born muggles and
being a squib is like the single worst
thing that you can be in the Wizarding
World in fact the word squib is
basically like a racial slur to them so
then why is it such a big deal if
they're kept out of Hogwarts they're not
magical anyway so the decision to send
those children off to muggle schools
makes a lot of sense rights well with
the exception of race private schools
can discriminate on the basis of things
like religion or ability but that's only
if they don't receive federal funding if
a private school receives even a dollar
of government funding they're subject to
anti-discrimination laws including
things like the Americans with
Disabilities Act here in the US or
disability rights in the UK that's the
one that would apply to Hogwarts and
Hogwarts receives funding from the
Ministry of Magic
JK Rowling even confirmed the funding
herself on Twitter and even though it's
barely mentioned in the books in the
movies I can confirm that the Ministry
of Magic gets its money outside of what
it receives from private donations from
Lucius Malfoy types from taxpaying
wizards and witches as evidenced by the
existence of the hexing tax
you see right here so what we have in
Hogwarts is a school that receives
funding from taxpayers that willfully
discriminates against the wizard born
children the squibs and that quite
frankly is illegal based on the letter
of the law as such Hogwarts technically
should be shut down by the government or
be required to open its doors and here I
thought that you were a guy who would
appreciate diversity Dumbledore and that
leaves only Xavier school which believe
it or not allows non mutants to study
there took some digging across a lot of
fictional yearbooks but for 10 issues a
non mutant by the name of Walter Lambert
speaks about how he earned his way into
Xavier school off of academic merit
alone a non mutant in the mutant private
school why you would want to go there
considering your school gets destroyed
every few months and half the curriculum
doesn't apply to your skill set is
beyond me but hey you could totally do
it
you know on second thought though I
guess getting taught pre-med by
Wolverine would be pretty awesome the
guy is an expert on healing after all
but all in all when the dust settles
Xavier school is the number one gifted
student University based on the
Princeton Review rankings which brings
us to the moral of today's episode what
we think these schools would be great to
go to in real life the fact of the
matter is that none of them would want
the rabble like us well you know what
they can keep their potions I'll see the
rest of you in home act today we're
learning about how to clean grout now
that is a real magic trick but hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
cut alright so you might not be learning
the most practical skills at any of
these schools but if you're eager to get
yourself some real-world useful
learnings then head on over to the
wisecrack channel we're constantly doing
fun insightful analysis of all your
favorite movie franchises in fact if
you're still watching this video it
means that one you probably liked it and
two you're probably here for more x-men
goodness hence me recommending to you
their analysis of x-men first class
which has some super cool insight into
Magneto's transformation throughout the
movie into the monster that he always
sought to destroy man just saying that
made me feel like ten times smarter plus
when it comes to their videos you can
by those sick eyebrows love those things
it's like a toupee for the upper eyelid
so anyway click here to check out the
wisecrack channel and then tell them I
sent you so I can rub it in their faces
that I sent a bunch of viewers over to
them it's all part of a friendly little
rivalry that we have it's not friendly
at all it's actually bitter bitter
rivals now if you'll excuse me next week
we kick off scary October by getting
dark and green see you then